[музика]
Доброго дня шановні колеги Доброго дня
шановні українці
ви знаєте Ну перш за все хочу сказати що
освіта була одним із тих процесів якій
Був дійсно
порушений під час 24 починаючи з 24
лютого під час навалу російської агресії
і дуже важко було сприймати коли в за
одну добу щонайменше один заклад освіти
заздавали або пошкодження або повну
руйнацію на сьогодні ми маємо жахливу
картину
230 закладів освіти які повністю
зруйновані і
1981 який пошкоджено при цьому Ми маємо
1180 об'єктів які знаходяться під
окупацією і ці цифри жахливі ми
здійснили переміщення 42-х закладів
вищої освіти
67-коли коледжі на з місцем часової
окупації до
суверенної території України і це
в повній мірі не дає можливості
розпочати освітній процес в тому форматі
який звісно був до війни
великі освітні ініціативи наших донорів
наших партнерів викликають лише повагу
лише вдячність і в цьому контексті
звісно ковід зробив певні коригування
щодо набуття освіти вона більшій частині
відбувалася в змішаному або в онлайн
форматі але при цьому Ми чітко розуміли
що онлайн
Ні в якому ні в якій мірі не замінить
повноформатного фейс у фейс спілкування
з між вчителем і дитиною і це в
будь-якому випадку відбивалося на якості
освіти наших дітей хоча при цьому мушу
замітити ті заміри які ми робили разом з
державною службою якості освіти давали
Нам принаймні оцінку 8% втрати якості
але коли наші діти вимушені були
покинути територію України під час
навалу російської агресії з 24 лютого
перебувати на в країнах Європи розповів
країнах Америки в Австралії в Японії
абсолютно всі партнери всі Міністерства
країн з якими ми спілкувалися які
приймали наших дітей були вражені від
якості освіти школярів від якості освіти
наших студентів від якості наших
науковців і дослідників тому звісно і
офлайн і онлайн формат не настільки
вплинув на
якість навчання адже наші освітні
програми побудовані таким чином що вони
на певний напевно напевно дистанцію
випереджують в тому числі більшість
країн Європейського Союзу і деякі країни
світу на сьогодні готовність закладів
освіти не Можна оцінювати остаточно адже
ми маємо перші позитивні кроки високої
якості зростання динаміки готових шкіл
разом з міністерством внутрішніх справ
разом з державної служби надзвичайних
ситуацій вже місяць триває плідна робота
якщо ми на початку говорили лише про
готовність 11% закладів освіти то на
сьогодні принаймні 36 закладів освіти
вже
[музика]
відповідними актами затвердженої їх
спроможність до повноформатного
повноформатного закладу Ми сьогодні
коли проводили спільну зустріч щотижнево
проводимо спільну зустріч з керівниками
державного служби надзвичайних ситуацій
з керівниками обласних департаментів
освіти і науки ми маємо вже сьогодні
більше ніж 30 тисяч перевірок
від ДСНС по всіх областях України маємо
певний перелік зауважень які необхідно
виправити і сформувати певні безпечні
умови для кожного з наших закладів
безперечно
е-е кінцевим бенефіціаром е-е і тим хто
забезпечує і взагалі-то визначає старту
освітнього процесу і форму навчання для
закладів освіти є засновники відповідно
до закону Про місцеве самоврядування
відповідно до нашого нашої концепції
децентралізації такими є керівники
громад
керівники військових адміністрацій тому
саме на них лежить відповідальність щодо
підготовки закладів освіти до старту з у
новому навчальному році і саме Від них
залежить в якому форматі буде
розпочинатися освітній процес Дякую вам
в рамках хочу знову ж таки подякувати
нашим партнерам фонду Східної Європи за
ту велику програму яку ми сьогодні
розпочинаємо безпечна школа щодо
обладнання укриттів в шкільних закладах
освіти в Україні є два конкретних
завдання які ми намагаємося спільно
вирішити це використання безпеки і
завдання психологічна підтримка адже
мало забезпечити наявність в обосховищ і
проведення там освітнього процесу під
час перебування в обосховищах це є
закрите приміщення це є певна певна
хвилювання кожного учасника освітнього
процесу як дитини так і так і педагога
стосовно тих обстрілів які відбуваються
назовні стосовно де де мої батьки Де мої
рідні Я взагалі відбувається Як же там з
моєї школи з моїм класом чи прилетить чи
не прилетить це величезна кількість
питань які сьогодні турбують в тому
числі і учнів і студентів і освітян
наших колег та в цілому і батьків і
дідусів покусів Це все всі ці питання є
основою взагалі-то завдання щодо
психологічної підтримки Дякую вам колеги
за підтримку Дякую вам за підтримку
освітнього процесу в цілому з поваги до
вас
Дякуємо пане міністр за те що роз'яснили
ситуацію і за те що відкриті до спільних
ініціатив заради відновлення збереження
і розвитку галузі освіти фонд Східної
Європи це українська неприбуткова
благодійна організація один з лідерів
громадського сектору в Україні фонд з
2008 року реалізував понад 100 програм
національні програми та місцеві
ініціативи і було скеровано понад 30
мільйонів доларів на вказані заходи
програми серед них портал дія цифрова
освіта платформа зрозуміло додаток
розмінування електронний урядування до
опрацювання української школи онлайн
тощо пане Віктору Розкажіть будь ласка
детальніше про проект і про можливість
для тих хто візьме у ньому участь
пані Світлана Дуже дякую шановні
учасники сьогоднішнього заходу Вітаю вас
вітамінів фонду Східної Європи
Напевно кожна звістка про
бомбардування українських міст просто
болю відбувається в серцях наших Ми
після чергового обстрілу Вінниці ми
вирішили що ми маємо щось робити
Використовуючи всі наші ресурси для того
щоб забезпечити безпечний навчальний
процес в школах Я хотів би принагідно
подякувати за активну позицію в розробці
цього проекту представника Міністерства
освіти та науки державної служби
надзвичайних ситуацій Міністерства
внутрішніх справ
органи місцевого самоврядування
обраних областей які активно долучилися
до формування
і самої програми і також
свої побажання і рекомендації щодо її
впровадження Отже нашим завданням до
грудня цього року був стане облаштування
укриттів школах та різних освітніх
закладах України ми сфокусували свою
увагу на чотирьох областях України і в
якій в цих областях почнеться очний
офлайн новий навчальний процес Але разом
з тим
в цих областях існує величезний ризик
бомбардування або атак ракетних отак це
Одеса Хмельницький Вінниця та Київ
в 20 шкіл 20 шкіл або навчальних
закладів Ми хочемо обладнати забезпечити
всім всім необхідним а самі укриттям
Крім того ми хочемо створити 4 модельних
укриття для того щоб використовувати їх
як краще практики разом з колегами з
державної служби надзвичайних ситуацій і
використовуючи їх рекомендації Ми хочемо
повністю
відбудувати і облаштувати такі модельні
укриття
для модельних укриттів Ми плануємо
виділити
близько 1 млн грн на кожне укриття серед
тих
16 додаткових які ми хотіли би
облаштувати ми виділимо тут по 350 тисяч
гривень для того щоб обладнати їх і
можливостями для безпеки Я маю на увазі
електрогенератори пожежогасники
засоби боротьби з пожежами респіратори
тому і подібне Крім того ми забезпечимо
такий пакет називається Комфорт коли ми
забезпечимо і лавки і ковдри і мати для
сидіння і подушки
біотуалети ємності з водою Ми також
добре розуміємо наскільки важливо
працювати вчителям працювати з
учнями протягом всього процесу і ми
розуміємо як пан міністр сказав що є і
своє обмеження тому що
простір дуже обмежений
група які знаходяться в укриті Зазвичай
вони різного віку і вчителям дуже важко
буде працювати але напевно найгірше якщо
діти будуть просто перебувати в укриті
під час тривоги тому ми хотіли би
розробити спеціальний навчальний курс
для вчителів і
передати його забезпечити чи в доступ
вчителям і офлайн і офлайн по тому як
поводитися як організувати процес
переходу в укриття і виходу з нього
перебування в укриттів для шкіри для
школярів з мінімальною психологічним
пресінгом або стресом
Крім того ми хотіли би в нашій концепції
такої безпечної школи я надзвичайно
Дякую працівникам Міністерства
внутрішніх справ за поводження і
координацією наших зусиль ми хотіли би
використовувати укриття як додаткової
освітній простір який би можна було
використовувати під час
занять школами і не в не під час тривоги
і ще хотів би буквально два слова
сказати що ми хотіли би показати цей
досвід звичайно працюючи з міністерством
освіти та науки за ДСНС Ми хотіли би
збудувати ці модельні укриття і показати
цей досвід іншим працівникам інших
областей інших органів місцевого
самоврядування адміністрації шкіл Я
хотів би подякувати всім партнерам Які
підтримували проект це українські
компанії Baker Tilly Україна
іпом Україна метро Кишин Керрі Україна а
також хотів би сказати що методично і
фінансово нас підтримує швейцарська
благодійна організація
надзвичайно дякую будемо раді подивитися
вже дуже скоро результати нашої роботи
це ініціативою за те що об'єднали
представників Бізнесу для сприяння
розвитку сфери освіти в Україні
пане Роман на сьогоднішній день Державна
служба з надзвичайних ситуацій потужно
працює і для безпеки освітнього процесу
Розкажіть будь ласка що вже зроблено І
що ще заплановано в рамках проекту
Вітаю колеги Доброго дня усім ну
державна служба України звичайних
ситуацій також є одним з учасників
процесу забезпечення безпеки проходження
освітнього процесу навчальних закладах
ми відповідно до доручення
прем'єр-міністра берем участь у
регіональних і місцевих комісіях по
обстеженню закладів освіти фактично ми
відпрацювали вже 19 тисяч закладів
освіти це вже більше 70%. у яких
проведені обстеження і відповідні
висновки є відповідні рекомендації більш
того для
надання практичних таких рекомендацій ми
розробили алгоритми відповідних дій
керівників і власників
балансоутримуючих закладів освіти як
потрібно облаштовувати сховище Які
найбільш Скажімо так
практичні поради можна використати Ну і
звичайно законодавчі вимоги до таких
сховищ коли вони можуть працювати Чому
вони не можуть працювати
на даний момент протягом серпня будуть
проведені навчання з абсолютно усіма
керівниками та посадовими особами
закладів освіти для того щоб надати їм
допомогу щодо організації заходів
цивільного захисту безпосередньо в
закладі тобто порядок оповіщення порядок
евакуації порядок дій в різних видах
надзвичайних ситуацій тому з свого боку
ми дійсно надаємо всю методичну та
практичну допомогу щодо
навчальним закладом щодо організації
навчального процесу в
максимально безпечних умовах наскільки
це можливо за кожним закладам освіти у
нас закріплений відповідний
відповідальний працівник який в режимі
24/7 готовий працювати і консультувати
фахівців відповідного закладу освіти що
стосується самого проекту фонд Східної
Європи для нас надій партнер ми
реалізуємо вже велику кількість
ініціатив спільних в тому числі про
розмінуванню і дуже приємно що така
ініціатива сьогодні розпочинається
спільно з підтримки Міністерства
освіти за підтримки Міністерства
внутрішніх справ тому що нам дуже
важливо показати Скажем так Еталон того
яким повинен бути сховище як його
правильно експлуатувати яким чином це
можна адаптувати в освітній процес тому
що Ну на жаль ми маємо бути готові до
тривалих загроз в цьому напрямку і в
тому числі в сфері
роботи закладів освіти тому
колегам Східну Європу особливо подяка за
реалізацію цієї ініціативи ми і
підтримуємо на рівні надання методичної
і практичної допомоги безпосередньо в
тих закладах де це буде відбуватися тому
готові до подальшої співпраці дякую
Дякую пане Роман за те що тримаємо
спільну і освітній фронт пані Катерину
Міністерство внутрішніх справ має свої
завдання для забезпечення створення
безпечного освітнього простору в Україні
Що можете про це розповісти
Доброго дня
пане міністр шановні присутні дуже рада
сьогодні бути на цьому Заході коли ми
бачимо наглядно як можуть співпрацювати
громадський сектор партнери і
підрозділи зокрема Міністерство
внутрішніх справ
Міністерства освіти і науки я перш за
все хочу сказати що
безпечне середовище для дітей це
досить багатокомпонентний такий проект
так би мовити і безперечно сьогодні
важливим питанням В умовах воєнного часу
в Україні є якраз таки забезпечення
права дітей на здобуття освіти і
міністр внутрішніх справ Денис
Анатолійович Монастирський він визначає
одним із пріоритетних питань це все ж
таки безпеку дітей під час освітнього
процесу тому Як вже було зазначено
сьогодні
підрозділи системи Міністерства
внутрішніх справ Державна служба з
надзвичайних ситуацій а також працівники
національної поліції сьогодні спільно
працюють з метою
зафіксувати виявити і зрозуміти
наскільки
готові заклади освіти до початку
навчального року що на сьогоднішній день
є насправді досить актуальним питанням
тому у всіх регіонах нашої країни діють
комісії з оцінки об'єктів закладів
освіти щодо можливості їх використання
можливості до початку навчального року і
станом 4 серпня вже дійсно
проведено огляд майже 19 тисяч об'єктів
закладів освіти це близько 70%
і вже визначено що
36% із тієї кількості які були
перевірені закладі освіти
можуть приступати до початку навчального
року
Разом з тим питання належного
облаштування укриттів залишається
гостро перебуває на часі сьогодні І я
хочу відмітити що такі проекти такі
ініціативи і такі програми про які ми
сьогодні говоримо
зокрема яка ініційована буде проводитися
фондом Східної Європи це є
чудовим прикладом того як за допомогою
кооперації зусиль місцевих органів влади
і наших міжнародних партнерів ми можемо
створювати безпечне середовище в школах
з метою належної організації освітнього
процесу дійсно хочу сказати що це не
перша ініціатива яка спіль
з Державної служби з надзвичайних
ситуацій проводиться з організацією
фонду Східної Європи і я маю надію
переконаний що не остання Тому що такий
ініціативи вони сьогодні є важливими і
потрібними Дякую Дякуємо пані Катерино
разом ми можемо багато зробити для
розвитку для майбутнього нашої країни
шановні спікери шановні учасники на
цьому наш брифінг завершено акцентую
вашу увагу що проект буде функціонувати
З 1 вересня 2022 року до 31 січня 2023
року потім за потреби він буде
продовжений або розширений Дякуємо всім
і Бережіть себе
[музика]